po isolations defy gravity to look like
absolute magic and today I'm going to
show you that move through five
different levels of
[Music]
difficulty Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I'm going to
take you through one of my very favorite
po tricks and show you just How Deep The
Rabbit Hole goes for it but before we
dive in I want to give a quick shout out
to the Friends of the channel big thanks
to dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroar light toys
spinballs and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non- business
friend of the channel Becca becklen
thank you so very very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission so let's be honest about this
right from the jump POI isolations look
like absolute magic no matter how long
you've been spinning isolations have
fascinated pois spinners for decades now
due both to their difficulty of
technique and performance as well as the
eye-catching results when you get them
down perfectly but as it turns out just
learning isolations is only the
beginning and there are so many ways
that you can take that idea and really
run with it so I'm going to take you
through five different skills levels of
poi isolations that'll take you from the
very Basics all the way to some of the
most difficult poy tricks I have ever
encountered starting with level one
beginner linear
isolations okay so some of you might
quibble with me a little bit on whether
or not this actually constitutes a
beginner move I personally think that it
does but your results might vary but
either way doing them is still simpler
than learning how to do a full isolation
on its own but the knowledge that you
get from linear isolations is not wasted
if nothing else you can find find a
point where you can get that nice sticky
feeling between your hands and pohe
heads that will lead you to getting down
the isolation later on in your flow
journey and real talk even if lni your
isolations aren't quite the real thing
they are close enough that they become
important once you do learn how to do
isolations as a transition tool to get
you back and forth between isolations
and other py tricks and of course going
back and forth between the extremes of
having your hands apart and then close
together is something that just explores
volume in a way that is super duper cool
for an audience highly recommend this
one okay so now let's get down to Brass
tax and actually take a look at
something that does really have the
characteristics of an isolation and that
takes us to number two beginner
intermediate horizontal isolations so
real talk I think that doing isolations
in a horizontal plane is super
underrated for several reasons number
one these are kind of like learning
isolations with training wheels that is
you get to play around with the motion
of them without necessarily having to
deal with gravity fighting you every
step of the way and number two these are
wonderfully functional horizontal plane
poov in general and I think we could all
use more of those in our toolbox whether
you're turning with them using them to
get in and out of cork screws or even
using them just to bring the PO to a
stop I think that horizontal isolations
are a lot more versatile that we give
them credit for but once you are up for
fighting with gravity and want to bring
those po into a vertical plane well the
next step along the journey is level
three intermediate Buzz saw isolations
so this is defitely the classic
isolation that when I say the word
isolations everybody's really thinking
of it it's important to remember that
isolating something is an adjective and
not a noun rather than being a discreet
trick in and of itself it's a quality
that is applied to a trick and that
classic isolation that we all know and
love is really just a buzs saw with that
treatment applied to it and my goodness
this is one of those rare poy tricks
that is absolutely amazing whether you
are flow familiar or somebody that has
never encountered po ever in your life
there's something about that capacity to
have the poy following along with your
hand define gravity and even it seems
like the laws of motion that just Wows
everybody and I love it but it's also
not the end of our journey isolations
may have been something that wowed pois
Spinners in decades past but they also
became a stepping stone to a number of
other possibilities so let's dive into
those level four intermediate Advanced
isolated hybrids so as you might guess
this is going to be my favorite entry on
this list of course one of the most
popular uses for isolations was in the
very first hybrid ever discovered by
Andy house way back in the 2000s this
would be extension versus isolation a
trick that people were dumbfounded to
realize embody two different timing and
Direction modes at the same time and
I'll be real with you I did spend some
time trying to think about which hybrid
I wanted to feature on this list and I
couldn't pick just one so you're going
to have to deal with all of them sorry
and where to begin here the classic
extension versus isolation hybrid the
cat eye versus isolation hybrid the
horizontal cat eye versus isolation
hybrid or maybe perhaps my personal
favorite Gunslinger versus isolation all
of them are awesome goodness so what
could possibly be harder than those
hybrids I'm so glad you asked cuz this
is my chance to show off a trick that I
almost never do and there's a reason for
it so level five Advanced isolated weave
this trick looks so cool and it is so
hard to make it look clean the concept
behind isolated weaves is really easy to
grasp once again you're applying the
concepts of isolations to a 3B weave the
challenge being though that it turns out
it's really hard to keep that motion
going with your hands separated by a
Poise width and do be aware that this
trick is basically impossible unless you
just have the most Sterling technique
with your isolations because it requires
you to basically be able to do your
isolations with your arms crossed and
that is quite the challenge even for the
most experienced po spinner out there
the first time I saw this trick on video
it was in the Arizona transmission video
from xan Moore and alien John I had
decided that I was going to try and
learn every single trick in that video
and this wound up being the last trick
on that list this trick actually came so
close to winding up on my five levels of
the 3B weave list but there were other
things that I wanted to show off so I
decided that this was the perfect place
for it to live but right now you might
be wondering hey Drex it's good to have
a list of all these tricks but how do I
actually learn how to do isolations
friend I got you covered I'm about to
start up a new unit of my live stream
classes and wouldn't you know it that
unit is specifically going to be on
isolations the drills that help you get
there as well as some of the techniques
that look similar to isolations and make
for great transitions in and out of them
if you're interested and checking that
out registration is open now over at
crowdcast doio directa po go check it
out and I hope you sign up and for an
extra bonus if you want to get 10% off
the price of the course you can enter
the code isolation at checkout and get a
discount hope to see you there what are
your favorite isolation based tricks did
I miss any that you think should have
been on this list go ahead and leave me
a comment and let me know and don't
forget to like share and subscribe to
help other people find this video and to
help my channel
[Music]
grow
thank you so much for watching real
quickly before you head out I have to
give a shout out to my awesome
supporters on patreon they make this
video and all the videos on this channel
possible and in particular I would love
to highlight my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now uh if you
would like to check out more videos that
I have done of tier lists it's a short
list just now but it's probably going to
get longer I will include a link to that
playlist down in the description uh and
of course if you would like to support
the channel I will include a link to my
patreon down there as well thanks again
for watching make sure to get out and
flow today and I will see you the new
video real soon take care now peace